you
tens of thousands of football fans are
already crowding into Miami this week
ahead of Super Bowl 54 and security
teams are gonna monitor the stadium
where the games being played from the
sky the ground and the water looking for
all types of threats from terrorism to
the corona virus Manuel Bojorquez is on
a patrol boat in Miami with a
behind-the-scenes look at this massive
operation many good morning so why is
security different for this Super Bowl
as compared to the ones prior well good
morning the simple answer is water lots
of it and a coastline to protect making
it very different from last year's game
in landlocked Atlanta and it means that
agencies like miami-dade PD will be out
patrolling on boats like this one
federal state and local agencies are all
working together to protect the game and
that also means plenty of eyes in the
sky it's a stunning host city but Miami
brings a whole host of unique security
challenges we went airborne with Customs
and Border Protection's air and marine
team and agent Todd Gail what are the
challenges securing the place like this
well first of all we're surrounded by
water so it's really a part that we have
our maritime assets out on the water
actively patrolling look at the party
[Applause]
this bird's-eye view is also critical to
monitor activity not just down below but
up here airspace and Blackhawk
helicopters will patrol the skies
looking for any unauthorized aircraft
including drones some of the helicopters
are equipped with infrared cameras which
can spot people on the ground and in the
sand and they will transmit those images
live to the command center here
miami-dade Police has tons of TVs but
they won't be watching the game so this
gives us an access to thousands of
cameras throughout the county that we
can tap into if something's going on and
this year Super Bowl venues are
scattered three different major event
locations Hard Rock Stadium is about 13
miles from the Miami Beach Convention
Center where the Super Bowl experience
is taking place and a concert venue
downtown that means additional fencing
and screening of everything and
everyone that goes inside is happening
at all locations inspections are also
ramping up on the water the Coast Guard
is establishing security zones along
this cane Bay and at Port Miami one of
the nation's busiest agents are on the
lookout for drugs and contraband
including counterfeit Super Bowl
souvenirs which are already popping up
and while patrols are already being
beefed up here in the water I can tell
you that officials say at this point
there are no known credible threats
against the game but there is another
concern the corona virus health
officials have set up a quarantine
station at Miami's International Airport
at this point though just a precaution
Tony no known threats but it looks like
they'll be ready of anything surfaces
Manny thank you very much